they think that anybody that doesn't
subscribe to their ideology is not a
Muslim the fact that this is happening
in Ramadan has very little to do with
ISIL and how they feel about Muslims
they think that anybody that doesn't
subscribe to their ideology is not a
Muslim well what we're seeing is an
increasingly desperate ISIL they lost
territory in Syria they've lost
territory in Iraq they're losing
territory in Libya anywhere that they
had stronghold they've been attacked
militarily what ISIL are now doing is
sending a message to those people who
are attacking them saying okay we may
have lost territory but we can still
attack you now the reason why Medina was
attacked I was online after the attack
had happened speaking to people who
support ISIL T and Iceland question
strike
why are you bombing the prophets final
resting place and they said look it's
turned into a shrine now people go there
and they pray to the Prophet Mohammed
they don't pray to Islam and shrines are
Haram in Islam therefore it's a fair
target this is the level of thinking
that we're at when it comes down to ISIL
if you don't believe in their ideology
you are simply the enemy and they want
to either kill you or co-opt you and
they're the only two options you have
the level of anger I saw emanating
particularly out of Saudi Arabia was
incredible people are very angry about
this attack and it's going to change the
way ISIL is perceived not just in Saudi
Arabia but amongst the Muslim more
generally
you
[Music]